If you’ve just watched The Matrix or you’re
a Californian who has gone a little overboard
on the weed legalization celebrations, you
might be wondering; how do I know that I’m
not just part of a computer simulation?
Does Super Mario think it’s pretty standard
to be attacked by suicidal turtles all day?
Maybe Kimmy from Candy Crush, never wonders
why she isn’t riddled with diabetes.
It might seem obvious to us that they are
completely virtual but who’s to say that
we aren’t part of a giant simulation?
Maybe we’re all NPCs in a computer game
So, let’s take the red pill and the blue
pill at the same time, because screw you Morpheus,
as we ask ourselves; is anything real?
Thanks to science fiction, we often associate
simulated realities with computers, but doubting
reality is far from a new thing.
The Greek philosopher Plato, who lived around
2500 years ago, wrote about the concept in
his work the Republic.
He pictured a cave with prisoners chained
to the wall and all they ever saw were the
shadows of others passing in front of a fire,
projected up onto the wall in front of them.
This is the only life the prisoners had ever
known and so they would understandably believe
that the shadows were actual people.
It’s similar to the modern world where we
look mainly at people’s virtual lives, though
social media, and we think of their actual
lives as far more exciting than our own, when
in fact they are having the same terrible
time that we all are having.
The real problem comes with this definition
of “I”.
“cogito ergo sum” – I think therefore
I am – but that doesn’t help us prove
WHAT you are.
Master Chief exists but he’s just a bunch
of code I can control…
John Locke, pointed out that we could never
actually know the real essence of anything,
we could only deal with its nominal essence,
meaning what we actually experience of it,
rather than the whole picture.
He said it was like looking at a clock face;
all you can see is the time it shows, you
don’t have any idea what cogs and wires
are behind it, making it work.
So as much as we believe we know how the universe
works behind the scenes, we’re still really
just clueless puppets.
Everything you experience comes in through
your various senses, such as your sense of
smell, sense of touch, etc.
But at the end of the day, all of these senses
end up as electrical impulses in your brain.
Daniel Kish had his eyes removed at just 13
months old, due to retinal cancer, and from
a young age he trained himself to echolocate,
using clicks with his tongue and listening
for the echo.
He became so proficient at this that he was
able to mountain-bike and tell the difference
between surfaces such as metal and wood.
And when neurologists tested him, they found
that his visual cortex was being activated,
so he was really seeing objects using sound,
not just hearing them, the brain had just
swapped around some of the inputs.
Your body also senses an astonishing amount
of data, more than you could ever realistically
process.
So if you wanted to create a fake reality,
you wouldn’t need to program in every tiny
detail, since only a small fraction would
be experienced by the user at any one time.
Right now there is air pressure acting on
every millimeter of your body, there’s light
bouncing off objects from countless things
outside of this screen you’re staring at,
and that strange pain in your elbow… well
I don’t know what that is and you should
probably get it checked out.
And this is why we have pain, it’s like
a red flag that makes you pay attention to
one specific area of your body, because if
you listened to all parts of your body, all
the time, your brain would simply be overwhelmed
with information.
So then, let’s take this a step further.
If perception is just electric impulses in
your brain then your brain is also just a
lump of quite fancy meat, full of electrical
impulses.
Any idiot with some bacon and a Taser can
recreate that.
So surely your consciousness is more than
just the material that makes up your brain,
isn’t it?
We call these things; substrate independent.
This means something that is more than the
stuff it is made up of.
Waves are a good example of this.
If you see a wave on the ocean, it has amplitude,
frequency, things like that.
And these properties are not a part of the
sea water, they are part of the wave and independent
from the water.
So the bacon and Taser combination may produce
some similar matter to a brain but it’s
not going to create the same conscious thoughts
like “what is love?” and “what was that
thing I was supposed to be doing right now?”
and “why don’t electric eels electrocute
themselves?”
…Seriously, why is that?
So even if your brain isn’t meat, if it’s
just a sting of code written by some scientist,
or alien, or a 2038 iphone app, that’s not
to say that your consciousness isn’t a real
thing.
All your ideas could be unique and original…
okay, relatively original at least.
Coding doesn’t mean that your every thought
has already been decided, just that the initial
conditions have been set.
And this leads us to our own AI.
As we build more and more advanced programs,
it makes the likelihood that we’re in a
simulation seem even higher.
Just think about it, if we can code simulated
brains, what’s to say we aren’t already
part of one.
Elon Musk once said it’s only about a one
in a billion chance that we’re not in a
simulation.
And he’s a pretty switched-on guy.
In fact, it may only be by creating our own
simulations that we are able to really test
our own reality.
Physicist Silas Beane, is one of many theorists
who has said that a simulation must have limited
computing power; it can only get as big as
the hardware will allow it.
So, if we start creating enormous simulations
of our own and those create other enormous
simulations, at some point we’re going to
use up all the processing power available
to whatever hardware our universe is running
on and we’re going to crash it.
Until that happens, or we somehow discover
the inner working of our reality, we can never
truly know for sure if everything we know
is just a simulation.
Thanks for the view, subscribe for more Thoughty2.